brown's bengals tonight now i don't know
if what i'm about to ask you it may
sound ridiculous
i i admit it it may be very prisoner of
the moment-ish
um and maybe it's just reflects either
how high
i am on one and how down i am on the
other
but after one start a loss at that from
joe burrow
in his career right now today
you starting a team you rather have
borough or baker
ooh but actually i don't think it's that
ridiculous of a question
it's not okay i'm releasing no i don't
no because you know baker was
a surprise if you go back he was a
surprise number one overall pick
at the time and he had a he had a good
he had a good rookie season then uh
he kind of fell apart in year two so you
know
i'd say right now i would go with uh i'd
go with joe burrow
i think i think joe joe burrow
because baker was great baker was
accurate in college he had some
really uh terrific numbers and he's got
it's got that
he's got that charisma that you want to
see from a quarterback but i think joe
burrow was a better
college prospect i know just one year of
insane production
at lsu but i think he was a better
college guy
projecting to the pros than baker
mayfield was fewer questions with burrow
than with baker mayfield okay and i just
kind of rock i kind of roll
i roll with joe burrow too i just like
his whole yeah i know joe's that dude
joe's that dude no but i say this though
look they lost that game against the
charge but they shouldn't have
because uh an opi on aj green on what
would have been the game-winning
touchdown i believe
ended up missing the field goal um he
looked great in that two-minute drill
uh looked great on that touchdown run
obviously we know how he looked coming
out of lsu and
what people have said to say about him
this off season
so i i would lean more toward burrow not
based off what i've seen from him
but just what i haven't seen from baker
mayfield which is
a transcendent guy you know what i mean
i haven't seen a guy
they're both number one overall picks i
just haven't seen a guy i i saw a guy
that
was taken by team number one overall
it's listen this is not revisionist
history i felt like this when they took
it to your point about it being
surprised
when they took him i felt like that was
a guy that they were taking like we got
to take a quarterback because we've
missed on so many quarterbacks or as
some as the case may be
passed on so many quarterbacks in the
past
that all right it's the best one of this
group in our estimation
so we're gonna take we're gonna take
baker mayfield says john dorsey who's no
longer there
and so you know it's like i just don't
know that he's the guy
that can bring out the best in his
teammates you know i
i had a lot of questions about him
coming out of oklahoma
those questions have not been answered
if anything they've been exacerbated in
the pros
um so yeah and but then part of me man
just feels like
is that his fault because every
quarterback and every coach and every gm
that comes through that organization
seems to suffer the same fate and so i'm
almost like
is it is baker is is baker does he have
shortcomings
or is he just not capable of rescuing
this franchise
from its curse i don't know well you
know what
since you went here already you're going
here i i i didn't plan to go here right
now but you know
it's on my mind so you you brought it up
you brought up the browns
and in both of us both of us are our big
time madden fans
maybe too much so right right yeah can
we tell the truth can we tell the truth
here yeah
too much we spent a lot of time
enfranchising
i'm not telling you a little bit you
still maybe spend a little too much time
on it
yeah a little bit too much i mean i i i
i
might you know download the online draft
classes and you know
it's true i may dabble a little bit and
try to turn some teams around
here and there you know you know back in
the day back in the day it's about
releasing i used to give up
i used to i used to just give away
systems just to protect myself
i gave i gave a couple to my nephews i
gave one to like some random kid i just
met this kid i was like hey you want a
playstation
i just gave it to him because i need i
needed to get it out of my life i was
spending too much time on it
i'm gonna go franchise mode on you real
time
okay i want you to think about this
seriously real time franchise mode you
mentioned the cleveland browns
and we know what kind of problems
they've had if i make you
ex i give you executive power you're the
gentleman you know the general manager
head coach of the cleveland brothers no
lifts to god's ears
yeah you can you cannot get rid of the
owner
that cannot be part of your answer the
owner is there
you got power franchise mode cleveland
browns what would you do
what would you do with the browns to to
turn that situation around if you have
alright so in fairness and this is why
you don't need to conclusions after one
start so like in fairness man
you know they got the brakes beat off of
them by maybe the best roster
in the nfl all right i mean they're the
the
the ravens are super bowl favorite for a
reason so
you know baltimore had their way with
them in week one
i really like what the browns did this
off season i'm not trying to avoid the
question but i don't
what i wouldn't do is blow it up because
they blow it up so frequently
they hit the reset button going back to
franchise mode you think that they're in
franchise mode because they're
constantly hitting reset
i would pick a course and i would stay
it whatever that course is
i thought they did a great job this
off-season upgrading their offensive
line
um i thought they did an awesome job
adding some pieces on defense they had
you know the unfortunate uh injury to um
to grant delpit the lsu safety who i
loved i thought would have been a
difference maker in the back end
so if anything i would stay the co i
would pick a course and stay it for
longer than a year or two
that means keeping a coach in place
keeping a front office in place and
keeping the quarterback because
this was thrown off today what if uh
week one
was a sign of things to come for the
bronze this year and if you have a new
gm
and a new coach that did not draft baker
mayfield number one overall
and let's say they bottom out this year
and underachieve again
and and and and the browns brown like
they typically do
do you go quarterback again if you have
opportunity
you might have to fight you might have
to
hey mike i'll tell you this this is why
this is why i said you can't get rid of
the owner
and i told you yesterday growing up in
northeast ohio grew up in akron ohio
shout out moeller avenue west side
all right so i grew up there and i knew
i knew the whole history of the
franchise you think about this this is
hard to do
art model art model this is on
his resume art model fired
paul brown bill belichick
and marty schottenheimer wow
come on and so so all those guys
obviously paul brown was successful
bill belichick was on his way marty
schottenheimer did the job you know the
drive the fumble all that stuff
you can be successful even with the bum
owner and i think they got a bum owner
right now
so you got to work around here first
thing i do
if i'm a commodity that the browns want
to hire i'm asking for an unprecedented
seven year contract
i i need a seven year contract don't
mess with me
all that all that means is you got a lot
of money coming to you when they fire
you that's all it really means
coming here don't matter to them if you
fire me it's gonna hurt i'm gonna make
it hurt okay
and then then i asked joe thomas to come
out of retirement i'm just kidding
all right so then the other thing the
other thing i would do is
i need somebody who's going to talk to
the owner i need like a ceo type
to keep him away from me because i think
you've identified the major problem with
the browns like i said nfl the talent is
so close
the best team in the league and the
worst team in the league there is not
this huge
gap in talent between a five win team
and a 12 win team
sometimes it's just organization
sometimes it's just stability
i need somebody to stay away from me i
need that owner to stay away from me so
i can just do my thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports